hey Conan here you're watching the 360
live pre-show and now we've moved out to
another exciting part of the officer of
Warner Brothers this is my assistant
Sonam of sessions area hi Sonam hello
how are you I'm doing well you and I
have been together how many years like
two years how long has it been that
eight eight to eight close enough big
difference probably moving on soon
anyway
sona's great son and I are like peanut
butter and what what do we like not like
jelly cuz those go well together no
peanut butter and like sauerkraut yeah
with asbestos in it but it's whatever
and this is we can see what sone is
working on right here which is she's got
the New York Times crossword puzzle that
she works on every day I usually say hey
Sona this is really important I need
this done really quickly it's about the
show and she says I got to finish my
here of times and then 100 and then
sodoku you do Sudoku sodoku sweet dope
every day and how to pseudo quit work I
don't even know well pseudo can you just
have to have you can't repeat the
numbers in the same row column or box
and I do the easy a easy level medium
level and hard level good for you thank
you very much does it ever get in the
way of work I'll be like wait a bit okay
and then this is your desk area it's
usually it's actually cleaner than what
I've seen usually you have a lot of
conan stuff here although i found out
that this was a joel mchale bobblehead
that some fan turned into a Conan
O'Brien bobblehead I've never made this
pup why that is so rude to take someone
else's bobblehead lots of Conan dolls I
don't know how to feel about this one
this is the one that reflects me
probably most accurately right yes very
pale yeah okay take it easy that's good
lots of fun stuff this is a picture of
sona you were uh remember when you were
young and you were a ballerina yes you
look really nice and happy there what
happened
I grew up um let's take a look at other
things here I'm just looking around your
desk
you've got Dwight Schrute bobblehead
again that can easily be converging to a
Conan
we'll head if you just make some simple
cosmetic changes what are you drinking
today well there usually is water in
that well what else do you have during
the day have you ever had alcohol during
the show days like when you're working I
I yet yes what did you have uh well like
a few days ago we had some champagne
with some Saint Germain in it which was
good champagne during the dirt during
the day yeah I mean you know it was just
kind of chill days so we we call it
juice juice time juice juice time that's
terrific sana oh and look this is great
this is a great sign for someone who
drinks alcohol at work you have up and
I'll look there are some pictures
there's me choking you with my tie
uh-huh it's nice to have that framed
there is me remember when I introduced
you to President Jimmy Carter and
Rosalynn Carter the first lady yeah it
was a pretty big day for you right you
know what it was that was very nice of
you to do look at I'm paying you a
compliment that's a genuine couple this
mustache sometimes can be used for me to
do an impression of your father so on a
sauna please why don't you Maddy sauna
sauna please is that kind of what he's
like no not at all I've met him a lot of
older and he does have a mustache and he
is a cool guy he's the coolest guy but
you got to admit if I you just can't
across me quickly you might think this
is your father
sauna sauna America a minute ago not a
more like just human skin tone that's
rude we have you read Murray wave your
way back there I don't know if you can
see Murray Murray is Jeff Ross's
assistants if she really has a job she
just thinks he has to do she's
constantly working because Jeff actually
works on the show I'm a jackass and a
fool and you enable me and you're an
enabler and probably an alcoholic and so
we have a good time and here's your
wall-e fine right here this is probably
only friend
and you're you're an adult I don't know
I think that pretty much takes you
through some oh and this is Sona trying
way too hard to put her Armenian pass
behind her she does this whenever people
come in to ask for her green card she's
like America I was born here really not
really I was born in this country she
washed up on shore here and I found her
in a bush gave daughter English by
having her watch various soap operas on
TV Falcons crest okay I'm gonna go so
know what you enjoy this Korean beer
that they've put my face on my face is
on everything here it really is your
life must be a hell it is okay that's us
peace out
take Tupac what I don't know isn't that
a thing kitties Tupac I'm trying to be
with the kids Tupac peace out
yeah
[Laughter]